[Musique]
karina gauvin merci nous accueillir dans
votre jardin oui ça me plaisait
distanciation sociale oblige voilà c'est
vraiment à 8 ans que vous avez eu cet
appel pour l'opéra la musique classique
le champ finalement comment ça se passe
vous étiez vraiment convaincu votre
affaire mais c'est drôle parce que
récemment durant la pandémie tout le
monde a fait du ménage d'ailleurs aidé
moi j'ai pas j'ai fait la même chose et
fait le ménage dans les tiroirs et j'ai
retrouvé des dessins que j'avais fait
quand j'avais 7 ans et ce dessin je me
voyais déjà chanteuse d'opéra avec eux a
donc c'était vraiment j'imagine un rêve
oui très un peu en arrière plan j'étais
animé par la musique c'est vraiment ce
qui est celle ci comme c'était le feu il
y avait comme un feu qui brûlait qui
brûlait le camp même si j'étais comme
assise sur une cocotte
il y avait un peu en dessous je pense
que c'est ça qui est et qui a propulsé
le travail que j'ai fait par la suite
toutes ces années qui m'ont kim wan où
je suis aujourd'hui
[Musique]
parmi les critiques à peu près tout le
monde s'entend pour dire que vous avez
une voix une et planante
comment vous avez trouvé votre sens pour
vous distinguer les autres repreneurs
n'ont jamais ça se passe que c'est
comment je pourrais dire ça c'est jamais
quelque chose qui était une
une quête pour moi parce que je pense
que d'abord et avant tout c'est
l'authenticité
ce qu'on veut c'est l'authenticité quand
quelqu'un quand un artiste viennent nous
chercher
c'est parce que l'artiste est
authentique a lui-même l'artiste a
connecté avec qu'il est profondément
donc on peut pas dire bon mais l'homme
moi je suis je suis une chanteuse
d'opéra et je veux avoir un son x y ou z
jeu c'est vraiment une
comment choisir une communion avec
moi-même finalement on dit souvent je
suis un artiste qui lie à 10% talent à
90 % travaillent dans votre cas c'est
quoi oulala moi j'aurais fait drôle
j'aurais ni tête 40 60 40 pour cent
talents oui oui pour moi quelqu'un qui
va se démarquer quelqu'un qui va
apporter quelque chose il faut avoir il
faut avoir un talent il faut avoir
quelque chose qui parle quelque chose
qui vivent quelque chose qui dit annie
qui est intangible que ton espèce de
dauphins avaient oui mais d une
connexion finalement qu'on ne connaisse
espèces de 2 une connexion avec l'âme de
la musique ou de l'âme de ce qu'on
recherche on cherche quelque chose
[Musique]
tout au long de votre carrière vous êtes
longtemps battus contre le syndrome de
la barbiche il s'occupe
est-ce qu'il ya encore beaucoup de
travail à faire dans ce domaine
poser la question c'est y répondre je me
dirai non ben oui les choses on change
les choses ont beaucoup changé
lui il ya beaucoup il ya beaucoup ce
phénomène là dans le monde de l'opéra
c'est sûr mais si on observe maintenant
ce qui se passe dans le monde
si on regarde instagram tout ça les gens
revendiquent comment comment ils sont
naturellement il revendique sa et 10
mois je suis comme ça et accepté moi
comme je suis que c'est plus parce que
on en fait ce qu'est ce que les gens
défendent disent ils disent en fait ben
je suis quand même je peux mais comme je
suis et c'est un peu ça j'adore c'est
laid c'est la vraie vie ce puis je pense
que le monde de l'opéra était tombé dans
ces espèces de d'artifice
pour moi c'est ça la musique c'est
quelque chose qui vit qui exprime
quelque chose au public que les gens
sont là devant nous qui ressentent
quelque chose qui est des frissons qui
se passe quelque chose dans leur âme
karina gauvin je vous dis le mot de
cambronne pour vos concerts avec
l'oiseau c'est 13 ans
[Musique]
et
et non
[Musique]